my name is Ed Clancy I think my biggest
achievements in sport the three gold
medals from riding the Great Britain
track cycling team my name is Ken Ahmadi
I'm an endurance track cyclist and my
key achievements are medals at the
Commonwealth Games European
Championships and World Cup events
I'm Philippines spread cyclists and the
two-time Olympic champion I'm dr. Rob
Child
I'm chief scientific officer at science
and sport I've been involved in cycling
for about 30 years
what makes British icon world-class of
the attention to detail in all aspects
of the sport we got the best
physiologist the best psychologist the
best nutrition nutrition is absolutely
fundamental to cycling performance soy
beans got huge metabolic demands huge
demands for energy it really is one of
the most physiologically demanding
sports nutrition is really important
part of cycling it's kind of like a
triangle I think you've got training
rest and nutrition on each corner and I
think without one light you can't really
do give us his file
there's no point whatsoever in doing all
the trade and all the hard work if
you're not looking after yourself in
terms of sleep our nutrition science in
sport works with British Cycling to meet
their nutritional needs with safe
effective products and we work very
closely with them to develop new
products that we also bring to the
market commercial for me my favourite
the science of sport product is the
overnight protein I've always been big
on sleep hygiene sleep quality I think
that's such an important thing for
recovery for me it's a no-brainer
getting some quality protein before you
sleep overnight
one of the things that makes track
riding so demanding on the body is
they're huge our outfits that we require
so up to 2,000 watts and what we know
from the physiology is that when you
produce high power outputs you get a lot
of muscle damage
this is felt as soreness and weakness in
the muscle and to repair that muscle
damage a product like reco rapid
recovery plus is extremely beneficial
the informed sport testing is pretty
important to all of us really be nothing
worse than having a positive test from a
genuine mistake from a supplement or
product that you take in to trying to
improve your performance genuinely so
today that's why we trust science and
sport